what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
rings of Power episode 6 today uh I know
some people who already saw this and
they said it's a good one and um I'll be
the judge that
my opinion Matters Most
not theirs you don't even know who
theirs is not his nah amwa
I am the one who speaks for the majority
always let's not forget that so with
that in mind leave a like always leave a
like that like button comes in handy
also subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction for episode 7 is up well
I'll tell you whether or not you should
like it and also full interaction watch
along as we sync up with your own copy
for the rings of power available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
cover a bunch of shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included and at the team of
prepper thank you for almost out of this
down John how are you I'm here how are
you
don't you only ask because I asked you
one day you'll ask me out of common
courtesy I'll interrupt you next time
yeah that'd be nice insane you know
how are you can go a long way that's
true that's a good lesson for you all
and me all right let's do it
I don't believe this man is Sauron
and just be so kind of obvious
this is the knife we reach out the ion
hunt of the euro to close off this
around these lungs
the Uruk dude this guy gives a great
speech I want his side Teamworks let's
do it
Adar for life
this looks like the movies yeah that
sounds like the movies
[Music]
damn what bold moves they just walk
through the door ain't even like burst
through it
hey we're here to kill you don't exert
when you don't have to
some cool slow-mo [ __ ]
go
oh he's gonna he's gonna take them all
out
yeah burn them to the ground
[Music]
you don't need no fancy Tower wow
foreign
this was an insanely clever plan this is
a great strategy you have the look of
your father
I was always tired I looked more like my
mother
told you
why aren't you sweeping [ __ ]
even one job to do
died at Birth we're sailing into the
Dawn and yet to leave
feels like the coming of night
she drowned
mic drop anytime someone asked me a
personal question I'm gonna preface it
with all that
signal the other ships
tell them to make all possible haste
It's a Wonderful transition shot I love
that
where will you hide it
no one must know
toss it into the bottom of the ocean oh
who cannot fight will be barricaded
inside this is to be our keep our
fallback Point how we going there and
start in the keep soon the sun will set
to your palm and I swear to you you
shall see it rise again do you believe
it
he went over the heart of the people
find the light and the shadow will not
find you damn this feels like Lord of
the Rings that would have been great to
add to your speech by the way
the show's really about single parents
[Laughter]
for the battle begins
plant one
oh
even the bad guy did it
the rest
we shall plant off so the battle is over
in the new carton
you and I
and a little house and a white picket
fence
[Music]
finally make some new life in defiance
of death plant some seeds right now you
know what I mean yeah
[Music]
just you you one orc you go alone don't
take back no no back and forth right
here foreign
oh no oh that was fast
Road sliced nicely done nice Bronwyn
God damn it we've all been caught on
fire again
ouch
look at that form though
posture
they're ready for the tavern
you're gonna have to go get more arrows
man
[Applause]
oh
foreign
wow amazing stunt work ah did he really
do that actually it sure looked like hey
yeah unless they pasted his head on this
old time
oh no
oh buddy wow
there's some great action in this yeah
[Music]
wow
look at me nipple chills damn
[Music]
great ass wire work here
yes right that's right
yeah go for the jugular
[Music]
come on
Jesus Christ painful
[Music]
oh oh it's in your mouth dude oh no oh
oh God that's like it's it's like Sam
Raymond close your mouth goddamn close
your mouth Andrew I can't get over that
foreign
[Music]
Smith over here kiss him again
plant those seeds now yeah get some orc
blood on those lips
oh yeah he drank like a pint that dude
while you were fighting that one guy we
took care of the rest we did the Army
you're welcome
forever
more a bit
does anyone have some orange juice
I'm feeling a little lightheaded
Bronwyn
what
damage helmets they just turned around
and fought for them immediately geez
will
wow what a great way to have a feeling
of a false Victory here comes the second
wave
no don't get in the line of fire
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[Music]
no don't do the vocal
foreign
like the wind whipping
she's more important she's the most
important first
technically your leader
help
oh man I hope they don't kill her off
she can come back from a shoulder wound
slight movement must be so painful she's
correct it's right through you
oh
[Music]
God
[Music]
the pressure on the wound
special stopped bleeding he's probably
like burn it or cauterize it yeah you
must have a sword in the fire somewhere
we have to feel the wounds of Fire
bring me some burning wood burning wood
seems like you get a lot of debris in
there well he's doing some Alvin [ __ ]
throw these trees all out of you no
[Music]
now this side
oh much coming out
I mean who hasn't cauterized the
mother's wound before well that
wake up
mother
check her pulse don't worry their tears
will bring her back
oh
daddy mom's back
getting like Shadow of Mordor video game
vibes
foreign
[Music]
look at them headdresses Ah that's a
great shot all the budget went to the
horses yes
[Applause]
this just got personal
Johnny testing
I say Anthony
I mean not that guy that guy
oh okay okay oh this is getting very
real oh [ __ ]
oh that is menacing
the woman next hello
yeah
wake up
it's under here
dude
how did Theo know he's always lurking I
thought no one was supposed to know
unless he just has that connection to it
nope
sabotage for you
oh hell yeah
[Applause]
they knew exactly where to go yeah jeez
[Applause]
this is pretty [ __ ] awesome
yeah dude
[Applause]
get him young Dwayne lieutenant
[Music]
just stay there for the rest of the
fight yeah I'm cool I'm cool
yeah
God damn this is amazing work here yeah
Commander oh my God they're meeting each
other
go get his ass
whoa dude
oh nipple chills it shows that shit's
doing it for me
even numbered episodes boy that is a
really impressive stunt work
yeah it's cool to see trick riding again
look at that he looked at her with all
he knows who she is
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
you got it you can do it
great shot god
[Music]
come on
oh
joust
thank God I did not want to see a horse
get stabbed
oh my God why don't you step on his hand
oh even better
you remember me
no
hahaha
they need him alive I need him alive
you don't know what he did did I
call someone you love
pain yes uh obviously Babs
child eat
your one cannot satisfy Thirst by
drinking sea water
he wanted to get caught it was part of
his plan and he wanted us to lock him up
in the UFCU
damn all the storage lines just kind of
came together I know except for the Nori
and all that they'll stumble across this
soon enough where is he
where's Sodom perhaps we should bring
all prisoners into the sunlight
I found a weak spot
on
devoted himself to Healing
Middle Earth
bringing its ruined lands together
perfect order
perfect balance the shadow
of dark knowledge
that kept itself hidden
even from him
no matter how much blood he's built in
his Pursuit
that episode was very essential
I killed Sauron I cannot believe that
you
and this Army's only Master my children
have no master
they are not children they are slaves
but each one has a name
perhaps you'll search for more God's
successes should have ended in your own
mirror
perhaps I shall Begin by killing you
the blood rail huh
if I can't do it you can't do it we need
a mediator in here whatever it was he
did to you
be forever
I never believed I could be
until today
hmm
if I could just hold on to that feeling
bind it to my very being that I
I felt it too
so in the flames bronwick
this is Lord halbrand
are you the king we were promised
I feel cornered uh
uh I mean
yes
accept your Birthright
he looks straight up like Viggo
Mortensen there I know
massive Strider vibes
it's cool seeing The Malt of cross paths
man yeah
could pay off it's not just guilt I feel
it's lost
when it was in my hands
gotcha give it to numenor
to toss into the sea on their Voyager
I'm not going to be by your side this
entire time
I'm not gonna make sure you follow this
through or anything
you thought you could placebo affect him
oh wait no
yes this is the son of a [ __ ] this
freaking guy
[Music]
you sons of [ __ ] didn't check it's
one of those release keys dammits
ugh
you've had hours to look at it and this
guy's probably gonna live a whole long
time
foreign
it's like Queen Region's nightmare
no either way
you have to learn to speak horses
Fielder
informs an unbreakable bond with the
soldier he bears
in time they become as one
even knowing the innermost feelings of
each other's heart
you know his feelings no okay
it's been a time talking to horses
you can teach me
oh
no
go sweep some [ __ ]
damn guy
[Music]
that's right when he went out uh outside
of the keep he said he sold him he's
gonna give him something or something
like that yeah just had an identical
cloth
holy [ __ ]
Jesus
[Applause]
you guys better get a move on yeah let's
get him back on the horses
[Music]
oh wow God
[Music]
go fight the mountain
wow I'll go close that thing myself
[Music]
thank you
oh he is slimy guy
[Music]
how she survived that
that was great that was a very gripping
episode it's great
yeah that was Fantastical dang I need a
I need to breathe for a second
yeah that was actually that was awesome
that was that was quite thrilling quite
uh punchy
yeah this was uh the first like just
truly you know exciting
suspenseful tension-filled episode and
uh it just kept escalating wonderfully
it was really just gripping and dark and
you fall for the Triumph and then with a
wonderful scale it feels expensive looks
expensive boy howdy and it's put to
Great use it was the first episode that
truly brought catharsis I thought
and there was wonderful payoffs and I
didn't even realize like oh you know
what it's [ __ ] exciting because
seeing these characters come together so
like separated for like so many episodes
now and you've been wondering like
when's the when's the tie-in of these
characters gonna happen there's still
some other characters who have to
full-heartedly connect
um if I don't know maybe the direction
of the show with the stranger the wizard
and and uh the harfoots will have a bit
of that Hobbit touch to it of yeah it
comes down to the little people they're
the ones yeah save the day they're a big
part of the Victorious nature of it all
um I don't know but as far as this
episode in particular I thought it had
just a a solid grasp on suspense and
tension and mood and with just wonderful
choreography throughout a lot of times
the choreography with a lot of its
angles and Runners and whatever it can
be really cool in certain sequences but
this had to be orchestrated from
beginning to end this had to have like a
Full Construction around it in order for
the emotional upheavals and and the
highs and lows to be really felt and uh
the the the downward and the sense of
loss to the the victory you know there's
there's elements of of the people from
numenor that that seem to hearken back
to like the feelings of when the people
of Rohan uh wrote in in The Two Towers I
I thought this was great and then it it
showed me like it showed me like you
know actually because I like more of
these characters
like when when the when the calm settled
When The War when the battle settled and
then I'm watching like a ladriel and
she's whooping ass I'm like yeah go girl
and then glad you're on Hall Brandon
when they're talking with each other and
uh you know like iron deer and Ron when
I've been in dear two in the beginning
even when other people were naysayers
about them I've always been quite
endeared to to that duo
um but yeah when she was dying I was
like oh [ __ ] I really don't want this
girl to die like I don't want to happen
and uh so yeah watching uh the the the
the thing that really put the thing that
really solidified for me that I guess
I'm more invested in these characters
than I realized was the the fact that
all the fighting had finished and then
we spent like 10 to 15 minutes with just
scenes and I'm like oh yeah I'm into
this okay yeah I'm actually really into
this and and uh yeah you know I think
that this show uh know I guess it's just
like it really clicked for me this
episode because yeah it helps to have
something that's truly exciting and to
finally have some like full-on action
sequences and battles and and all that
things that you feel like you you you
were promised with something like this
IP uh this specific franchise the budget
surrounding it and you know things that
you've been wanting to see be paid off
but what would impressed me most it's
something that I think is often very
overlooked
in terms of action can be the stunt work
of horse riders and you know actors
having to train to do that like that
shit's really [ __ ] dating that's a
dangerous stuff and you know when
they're doing those like Fast takes when
they're I don't know if it's like how
sped up it is and whatever but you know
the when they're like running through
the woods that's that's some really
dangerous stuff and they don't even have
helmets on when they're doing it so when
you're watching them all ride incredibly
fast uh I I found that like it's cool to
see like the practicality of it brought
to life and even some of the wire work
when you know uh R and deer and that orc
are going toe-to-toe the wire work mixed
with a little bit of some slight CGI to
enhance some motion smoothness and
whatever
um I I thought was really well executed
yeah this was uh this is a really
gripping episode and then uh the ending
results with the characters just chit
chatting with each other and of course
like getting information on Adar who
urukai
it sucks man I just get the dwindle down
man I feel like rocks are are much
better I mean this one it must be right
Rock High Rock how do you say it
this is urukai yeah which is something
yeah they're like slightly more cunning
and a little more like less feral more
intelligent maybe but I think the urakai
have like man DNA too or something like
that I think that's part of where that
comes in
well still have that that scene with
Galadriel I thought was great and and uh
the character moments I thought brought
real intensity so yeah I I think that
this was um
uh this episode made the other episodes
feel suddenly worth it and I felt like a
good payoff and it didn't need to check
in to elrond and Duren for me to enjoy
it and so I think having having this
finally brought in you know it's like
does that make every the episodes that I
wasn't fond of suddenly you know great
or something I wouldn't say that I would
say that that the patience and the
payoff I felt the payoff I felt a reward
and I felt like oh I actually really
care about what's going on versus this
looks cool finally some cool [ __ ] I
found myself emotionally invested in it
like even when there was an action but
like the reveals of the people who had
just decided to fight with uh the Orcs
was there's a there's a punch to the gut
there man and even the reveal with the
although I do think it's a little silly
that they've been like no one picked up
on the on the blade uh yeah it's like
come on one one of you guys had to have
like been like this is it especially
that guy that that shifty old guy likes
rifling around I feel like somebody
would have noticed him yeah and
especially because the show established
that it's okay if you know people touch
this thing like certain people can't
like you don't want to put it in Theo's
hands
um however you know like you see you're
looking to come on break you know yeah
so I think I think like after hours of
just everyone under the assumption like
no this is it
I feel like they could have noticed uh
they would have noticed earlier but for
the dramatic effect and for the reveal
for the storytelling uh yeah you know I
think it has a good big moment at the
end too you know and even for Galadriel
of having the Victory and then looking
around it oh my God you know I guess I'm
motivated these people into battle and
now look what's become and now we've
brought her out the exact thing we were
hoping to avoid yeah because this
mirrors Queen Regents nightmare
um so yeah uh that was great you know
like it wasn't like non-stop uh you know
details and expositions so there's not a
whole lot for me to really talk about
but so yeah I feel like that's uh that's
my opinion on this episode I thought it
was I thought it was fantastic I thought
it was great and uh
I I'm really looking forward to next
week's episode yeah it's the first time
I've ended with like I really want to
see how this plays out now yeah yeah 100
I think there's something about a battle
like this that yeah it's part of Lord of
the Rings like you need that yeah yeah
you needed it it's not like oh you guys
just like action I'm like no you need it
no because it is an epic and and that is
a part of it no matter what whether it's
the Hobbit and you're battling a
fearsome dragon or it's you know the
Saga that is Lord of the Rings and is
the Clashing of armies and yeah the
battles you know a war is battles spread
out over time and I think something like
this yeah it does a really nice job of
making everything feel very immediate
and very intense and it takes uh it made
the map feel more fleshed out to me
because up until this point cutting
around all these places they felt very
disconnected from each other to it to a
point where when you know uh the new
minorians were riding in to you know the
rescue so I was like oh yeah this is
where they're going you know whereas
before I felt kind of detached from
details like that and so yeah this uh
this really brought the map into better
focus it brought the conflict into
better focus I liked and pretty much
everything you said like there's some
really beautiful impressive moments
where you're sitting there going like
this looks like it was done in camera
and I can't tell they had a horse run
through that gate and then some other
you know Crazy Action thing happening in
the foreground like there's really great
framing it's really well thought out and
Yeah like every character has to kind of
Express through
you know action not just like battle
scene but you know it motivates a lot
more you know internal uh life on
display as you know physical Stakes take
hold and then yeah it rings the contrast
really nice when there are these brief
moments of reprieve for characters to
reflect on the moment or you know try
and rally each other like there's yeah
there was a lot of
I feel like the show can often Overlook
the element of humanity that is
necessary to endear us to characters and
this managed to give us like way more
action than we've had thus far there's
some action-oriented episodes a battle
episode and yet it also brought with
that I felt a kind of humanity you know
among all those things while the
conversations and like you said the
character beats don't get
amazingly Rich they feel well
proportioned to this episode and okay at
the end yeah
and uh characters like Adar even still
have that like very engrossing sort of
okay like you know you're one of these
dark elves you're an ilk of which we
haven't seen as much of as of Lord of
the Rings and the hobbits so there's
something interesting like the Orcs
continue to have this very interesting
quality to them as this show uh kind of
does its thing and I'm really pleased
with that and uh and yeah like the whole
reversal with them fighting their own
was really cruel and heart-wrenching and
like something I never would have
thought about and uh and yeah like they
got me with surprises they got me like
tense with the just efficacy of the
action and yeah I was caring about every
plot line even a silver talking to
elendir you know about uh you know just
afterwards in the aftermath of
everything you know kind of wanting to
uh uh rise to that purpose and you know
the horse kind of of knowing that his
that he's off that he's rattled and kind
of needing to confront his own emotional
self but also to kind of open up to his
dad like there is you know the they gave
everybody a moment or two to feel you
know human amidst these stakes and I
thought that was was great and then you
know you have a bunch of badass stuff
and then you have a devastating you know
uh Elemental you know flooding slash
volcano scenario to cap it all off like
it is it is like that really
heart-wrenching reversal where it's like
you spend the first part of the episode
being like yes we're killing it we're
winning oh sh oh [ __ ] no we are not
winning we just wiped out some of our
own people and then we get this another
Rush of catharsis as numenor shows up
and we get to live in the celebration
afterwards and yeah that is hollow for
some people but for you know the
Infantry at least it is you know a
moment of togetherness and of hard one
sacrifice and then and the ultimate you
know just just plummeting of your of
your stomach and heart strings comes in
the in the form of that final blow with
the sword key and all that stuff and it
shows you the dangers of the sword key
it shows you the uh of like oh yeah you
really should not let this get out of
your your hands like that that is really
bad yeah and the way they talk a little
about Sauron and you know like oh I
killed him myself no you didn't you know
or he went off to to focus on healing
the land and things like that like it
adds to that Mystique too because you're
like clearly this is of his design and
this seems like you know one in a a
sequence of rube almost rube
goldberg-esque you know machinations
that will then you know topple The
Dominoes that'll lead to the outcome
that they've been trying to prevent Our
Heroes have been trying to prevent this
whole time that we've been watching the
show yeah this was really engaging and
like well-rounded and connected and and
a good example of when you take a little
time away from certain characters you
can get more out of other characters and
now I'm excited to return to L Ron and
Duran I'm happy at some point to return
to the hard foots but I don't like CR
that I wasn't missing them from the
episode which I think is good yeah yeah
I wasn't like amuse me who these
characters I actually
really care about I I thought like what
a hall brand and like well Hall brand I
felt for Hall Brand's moment when he
does I I really thought he was a
character I could give two shits about
and then when it came to the moment when
he's with Bronwyn and he has to this is
his moment like I know he he wrote into
action and everything but for him to be
like yes I am the king I felt that
moment and then the the joy and the
Euphoria of his people feeling like they
they have their leader back with them
there's hope yeah and then even even
having such a a dark moment with
um adorable
with Adar and then when they sat down
next to each other and the conversation
ended with them feeling like there's
light with them fighting side by side
there's hope you could also feel that
there's a a tragedy coming their way
even with the cell door you know we know
the tragedy that is that is to come and
I think the way they've been flushing
him amount is better because I couldn't
quite tell at times what they wanted to
do with the steel door because sometimes
it just seems like a bit of a selfish
brat and other times he's like I want to
fight for something I don't really know
why and and then there are other times
where he he seems to like lean into the
nepotism of like I want Power without
having to do all the work so I wasn't
really sure where they're going with him
seeking direction for sure and now I
think they've really set up for him to
have such a tragic moment where he
becomes a man who is very much revered
and very honorable to then make a
decision that we know he's going to make
um down the road that will be uh just a
tragedy for people like he's gonna build
himself up to this level and and have
what could be a glorious moment to then
mess it all up yeah so yeah I think that
the way how they're the way they're
fleshing this all out is really it's
starting to it's really working for me
now you know and this episode really
clicked and if it could just stay
consistent for two episodes in a row for
me then I'm like all right all right
yeah yeah there we go good job
numbered episode next yeah because I
know there are people who've definitely
been like liking to loving every episode
thus far and it has been the even
numbers of progressively caught every
even number we're like that's the best
one so far
and I I really think that this one had
just a wonderful construction around it
uh it was like this is a hard thing to
structure and and it's a lot to
choreograph and a lot of moving pieces
and a lot of choreography so this is
really impressive like this is a really
impressive episode and I think the guy
who plays Adar is great you know I I
like I think out of anyone the way how
someone's written adar's the best uh one
of the best because he never falls into
Villa any camp and and just like oh it
doesn't matter I'm we're going to kill
you anyway we're going to win you know
there is a he he he
wears the tragedy on his performance
sure of someone who once was just is an
elf and then had a dark darkness
um consume him
and he wears that really well and that
there is a pathos to that character
where you don't feel like there's hope
for him
uh but you feel like there was a person
of the past who maybe was not so evil
because he because of the compassion he
has for the those he leads and the way
he sees Sauron even like it's the first
time I feel like someone said like yeah
he he disappeared to try and go heal the
land and even though you know that
there's you know evil Darkness you know
Gathering there it's still through that
character's eyes makes Sauron a bit more
interesting too yeah yeah this is great
this is a great episode this is great
there wasn't a single thing I had a
qualm with other than that a little
thing of I don't know I'm gonna get some
[ __ ] for having a problem with that but
you
you should have checked you should you
should abs every time you grab that
thing you should make sure it should be
a moment of okay yeah we got it should
have checked yeah
should have been like this doesn't feel
like this I mean the way it feels does
not feel like a little Hatchet like that
I'm like how heavy is the blade of that
thing because yeah you had this big ass
meaty hooky you know you Hilt of a sword
the design of an ax is very different
yeah
yeah it looks like a stick and then the
curve the rectangular curvy you know
thingy and then uh the plate and yeah
come on I feel like there's a lot
working against that moment personally
sure at first I thought it was just like
a test of like just give this to them
and let it go and yeah placebo effect
what you said and then I was like uh but
I mean I guess you can you can argue
that because it's off screen for long
enough blah blah but at the same time I
feel like yeah especially after all they
went through hiding it I feel like you
wouldn't no no one like I feel like uh
uh Aaron deer were like keep it on his
person I feel like Aaron dear would have
known yeah I feel like Aaron deer would
have noticed it by feel I feel like yeah
yeah
but then again I don't know maybe it
doesn't come show sucks same way I knew
it I knew they could have sucks we've
been lying to ourselves this whole
review terrible show no no no it's just
uh whatever wall Drake or whatever that
character's name is he's just uh he's
just got that much more cunning from
hanging out with Adar
all right guys well what did you think
about this episode did you like it as
much as us leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that Bell two more
episodes left finally got me to the
excited point it's gonna be good good
finale good to be here all right guys
thank you so much for being here and
those who have like if you if you if
you've like stuck with us on our journey
especially one of those people who's
been like
um man I really love this show and they
don't they haven't been loving it as
much as me but so I appreciate those who
just stick with us through willing to
tolerate our differences in opinion yeah
and uh if we've had some opinions thank
you if we haven't thanks I mean just
regardless thank you for being here
[Music]